hello guys we are still at South by
Southwest doing some more interviews
thanks to Commissario tequila a huge
thanks to them because that's the reason
we're here and that's the reason why we
could talk about movies that I can't
even begin to describe to you right now
like extraordinary I I don't even know
how to explain this to somebody so I
think I'm gonna let you guys do this and
I just put before you even give a
synopsis I just want to say any synopsis
will not do this movie justice in terms
of like what you see in the tone of the
movie so I don't know who wants to do
the synopsis duties but what is
extraordinary about it is I suppose the
supernatural comedy rom-com it's got a
lot of those elements it's about a
lonely driving instructor who has
supernatural powers and she needs to use
her powers to save a virgin from an evil
rock star I'm the evil rock star so for
this one where did this idea come from
because there's so it seems to me at
least like there's so many different
potential starting points so what's kind
of like the spark that inspired was
actually a magazine or a newspaper
article very short but not as long as
the Philip and I page an older couple
who are just have very ordinary people
who happen to have supernatural powers
and it's like they they do this on the
weekend instead on top of their normal
jobs they just kind of go around they're
like ghosts Saunders I guess yeah but
the ghosts the thing about it was the
ghosts are actually just not scary at
all they're just kind of you know we if
you became a ghost you wouldn't
necessarily be terrifying
it would just be still you in ghost for
me I started to think about that while I
was watching the movie because in most
instances the ghosts are just doing
something that they would either want to
do if they were still around or just
something in their everyday lives so I
started a picture like what would I do
and I'd probably just be like home
feeding my cat or something I've just
I've just come to a realization that
probably most ghosts like if you're
getting haunted by a ghost you're
probably an [ __ ] ghosts just want to
do their thing do whatever and if
they're coming to haunt you it's because
somebody wanted to [ __ ] with you when
they and like you they have grudges
against you so if you're getting haunted
by a bunch of ghosts you were you
deserve it and it's just like a
pissed-off person
we I'm developing the theories yeah we
watched like we were thinking about
ghosts a lot obviously when we were
writing it and then we started watching
lots of like online videos and like when
you watch that stuff on YouTube it's
always like just a chair falling over or
a locker door closing in a school or a
pencil moving and they're the ghosts and
the hauntings that like tiny hauntings
are the things that actually people
capture on camera all the time because
their fake demon chasing somebody you
know movie about given that comment I
assume you're not believers at all
because I'm fascinated by this stuff
we're Irish so they yeah they're real
but everything else is a movie well I
believe I believe like a locker door or
Jerry falling over more than I believe
you know a JD Minh you made me believe
in the movie can you tell me a little
bit about bringing maven to the fold
here because I know she developed some
of the script with you guys she did
maybe it's amazing stand up and writer
and me and under huge fans of hers for
years we were friends with her we'd
worked she'd made this amazing TV show
in Ireland that was sort of a cult
classic where she she cooked with her
sister and it was or it was like stand
up on cooking at the same time it was it
was amazing called fancy vittles and me
and anda did the titles for that TV show
we directed them and stuff and true that
we kind of met me and then we used to
hang out a little bit in Ireland and
then when we had the idea for this movie
it was always gonna be made as the star
like as the lead leading lady she's just
so funny and we just wrote it with her
voice in our heads and then Maeve came
in and took took that it made it even
better again you know to put her own
spin on it was amazing when did the idea
for well to play this part pop up did
you write that with him in mind too
because I seen the movie I can't see
anybody in that role presenting question
to them in which I have to hear how many
people
we had a really long list and Hanks said
no obviously bono said no no and then we
went to what did you think when the
script first
you know crossed your table there cuz
were you able to picture it at all cuz
kind of like what I was saying at the
beginning I feel like on paper you don't
really feel kind of like that Electric
vibe and that specific tone of comedy
well the thing these guys did first of
all I was just in the hiatus for last
man on earth and and those seasons are
super grueling to do so I the last thing
I wanted to do was do any kind of work
but I was gonna go to Ireland on
vacation so I thought geez maybe I
should read this just in case and when
they sent it they not only sent the
script but they also sent like a tiny
little teaser that that some of it is
actually in the movie it's a lot of the
stuff from the beginning like you know
it goes a krav oh that thing has seen
the tree the teaser that's kind of what
I saw in the beginning so you you know
the tone right away and also I don't
know the tone as I was reading the
script just made sense to me anyway so I
I was very very excited because then I
found out that these guys we're gonna be
directing it too because you just the
script is so full of very specific funny
jokes that you knew if if the people who
were directing it we're also the minds
that were able to come up with that kind
of stuff that you're in very good hands
they that in a really good way cuz a lot
of times somebody somebody could take
that script and just make a completely
different movie but the tone of it I
that's one of the things I love so much
is that tone of that movie is just right
very stupid that's my highest compliment
that's so much heart to I mean that felt
like the backbone of it to me bringing
up that teacher though I was reading
that the Irish Film Board funded that
I'm not sure if they were involved in
the actual production of the movie but
it was making me wonder cuz I've applied
to film funds before and I'm a big
horror nut and I know sometimes it could
be difficult to kind of like crack that
door open so I'm just curious with
something as Extreme as this does the
Irish Film Board embrace that well Dave
ak they were amazing actually the Irish
Film Board and they existed like nurture
talent and I'm so when they gave us the
money to make that it it it's actually
what unlocked the rest of the funding
because when people saw that they went
they realized what the movie was going
to be like so yeah it was really
important we'd written the script and
probably had different versions of it
for about a year or two you know that
we're playing around and showing to
Maeve and trying to get funding first
and then the teaser that we spoke about
the little short thing was about five
minutes long and when we made that which
which the Irish Film Board helped us do
was kind of like a day long sheet but
just kind of gave you the idea of the
movie it seems we made that teaser
people just read the script with that in
their minds and were able to just
picture the movie much easier and the
funding funding just flowed in stopped
giving they said you should double the
budget it's the best experience we're
gonna try to jog a buck for another I
sign on kind of sequel there you brought
up that you went through a couple
iterations of the script here I'm
wondering what changed from draft to
draft also because like I walked out
thinking I would totally spend more time
in this world where the idea and the
characters just seemed to suit a series
format today
go on we feel the same we were obviously
like the most the most fun was writing
stuff like the kind of procedural
hauntings and that sort of stuff that he
where she's going out and they're
investigating a tiny little thing so we
definitely have loads more ideas that we
didn't use in this group that we'd love
to you know put into something else or
our work work in the world of
extraordinary and he also when you see
the film he liked her Dodds
TV show was so much fun to make as well
it's like a really small part of the
movie but it's kind of a show that's set
in the 70s and in rural Ireland where he
goes around you know explaining
different ghosts and hauntings so
there's a big world that we could
explore there as well I think it would
be really fun to go back into it at some
point I like the sound of that and one
of the craziest things about this movie
to me is that you guys are first-time
feature directors and this does not look
like an easy production to handle just
in terms of you know some of the the
visual effects you probably have going
on all the locations so is there
anything about jumping into your first
feature that made you think like oh
that's how that works or oh I didn't
know that I needed to do that well we
knew quite a lot about the effects
actually and other stuff from making TV
commercials which definitely helped and
I used to be a kind of a VFX artist so
that helped also but I know we know
quite a lot about that side of things so
I think it wasn't as daunting for us as
it may have been had we not done so much
of it before I also think that we you
know when you're doing a project like
this for the first time you don't know
how scary it's gonna be and you just
really want to do it and I think most
people just want to be as ambitious as
they can on the first one you don't have
time to to stop and realize that as well
because every day we run out of time
every single day with with the budget
and the amount of stuff to get through
in the period of time we had with
first-time directors you would think
that they would just be going crazy and
these guys you never knew how impossible
every day was supposed to be because
they were so relaxed we had some very
crazy days we were running out of time
especially towards - there's a big set
piece kind of at the end of the movie
towards the end I thought we were both
like we had two different rooms shooting
at the same time so that helped having
two directors I was in room and he was
in the other we never done that before
we split into it like shot stuff so when
we got to the editor I I saw stuff that
had that shot that I'd never seen only
one bit is the bit where we'll fold
and where he falls where he falls down
the hole was in a separate room while
Mike was in the other room shooting the
bit where sailors giving birth oh yeah
they were shooting at the same time I'm
supposed to yell I'm sure your audio guy
loves know our DOP was amazing as well
James Mather
he shot like Frank that movie he was
just running in between setting up shots
of them coming back in there are so many
specific visuals here where it feels to
be like you mapped out quite a bit of it
so what do you go to set with in your
hands just to make sure you get
everything so that when you piece it
together in the Edit room it actually
flows well we're dot section we were
ready we head towards a storyboarded
like we really had to storyboard all the
end of it because it's really
complicated so he storyboarded it the
hell out of it we walked true as Ron
says like it's kind of we actually have
a photographic storyboard of then we
gave that to a storyboard artist to draw
we had one location so it got confusing
though because we'd have to switch
there's only three of us doing it so I
would stand in as Christian but then I'd
also be Sarah but we only did that I
think in three of the bigger set pieces
but the rest of it was just shot lists
so just all the shots we wanted which is
written day and as opposed to drawn what
was just winging it as well but like you
know it's pretty obvious what to do when
it's just two people talking one burning
question I have just because I think one
of the things that I'm gonna remember
most about the screening last night is
that the person that was sitting next to
me every single time
a certain character vomited I mean like
she sucked deeper and deeper in her
chair her eyes cat her hands were
covering her eyes the entire time that's
great
how do you do something like that what
is he eight actually throwing up because
that always stresses me out I remember
when we were shooting it we didn't
really it was not meant to be gross at
all we just kind of did not have active
plasma comes out yeah and there was only
one we did a screening a test screening
and people were like going a gross we
thought we actually well that I copped
on it was actually quite gross it didn't
occur to me yeah it was very funny it
was actually some kind of we did a day
in pre-production with Bradbury dr.
Barry Ward and obviously we nearly had
to be speeding up ectoplasm a lot during
the movie so we we mixed up all
different colors all different weights
of it it's kind of sugary watery stuff
that the makeup department helped us
make breaking sodas right we did like a
camera test and Barry tried at lots of
them but he was a total trooper a look
that you actually enjoyed doing it and
weird like didn't taste too bad I think
we played this game called would you
rather and one of my go-to questions
gonna pose to you well would you rather
have to fake sneeze or fig vomit in a
scene fake vomit for sure without a
question I'm just a bad sneezer it's
very difficult to do I'm a better actual
vomiter than dry Hebrew like something
driving is it really driving it's like
sneezing for me in that it's just hard
to do realistic I I could I pictured the
saliva rushing that's good you just
think about this a lot of it going and
your your saliva glands kind of
so many more questions but we have to
wrap this up so I want to tell everybody
out there keep an eye out for
extraordinary I can assure you you have
never seen anything like it guys thank
you so much for your time today and
other huge congratulations like and
share this interview is always another
thank you to Commissario tequila for
letting us be here and talk about this
movie we will
see you soon with more at South by
Southwest coverage thank you
you